え ba をグランデーコンチビデオフィッシュやっきれい小ネタすばーがー資金繰り
スペック cheeza 版地図はだ無事ず町黍レフェリー額は死んだチキンタツこれ
ではグランてれ敷地いい
まあ製黒ストロベリーこんにちはパドル冊までお肉を禁止して約1か月ソニック時代
本当ね村スキーじゃないから焼き肉がいきたいとかと気にならないんですけど
マックが食べたい米の俺が mac で食べるのせいぜいえびフィレオがフィレオ
フィッシュぐらいなんですよ
[音楽]
いやだーーーーどうせもビッグマック食べなくなってしまったんですよ
bar ビッグマックマックハンバーガー食べたいけどを行くで食べれない俺とっぽい
んだ
で思ったんですけどもお肉の1ばいいんじゃねっということで前面にお肉を抜いて
もらいましたこうやってみると結構種類ありますね今マックるっていうハンバーガ全
種類でございますそして全ていう人で鶏肉豚肉
抜きと
なっておりますつまり普段スって食べないんですけど今の僕はそこじゃ何でも全部
食べるという設定でございます一方ファストリのハンバーガーがすべてを肉抜きで準備
して頂きました
big luck も食べたいんですけどもここで僕が知りたいのはお肉内の
ハンバーガーで一番美味しいハンバーガーはどれか検証していきたいと思いますこれが
やった奴いないんじゃないか全部覚えか入ってないですからねちょっとして
これによってにクヌギも美味しいバーガーが見つかるかもしれないとすれば僕は今後
マックに行ってもそのハンバーガお肉できるためからおいしく肌を食べるんじゃないか
つまりもう号デーに僕が判断を食べるわけですよ
というわけでさっそくやっていこうと思いますが前者でお肉抜きでお店にたログとか
スプーンでが迷惑行為見たかったんで事前に電話してマックさんに準備して頂きました
ご協力ありがとうございますイヤーカフ見た目ていきますかまずは普通にハンバーガー
から食べてチョコでがあるな看板が食べていきましょうじゃあ薄いユースゆ推しなんか
が
まじかピクルスバーガーだしてますねいただきますけどこれで美味しいかもしれないん
だな
うーんなんかねホットドッグのフィスって感じです
なんかね逆にいいんじゃないか全然食べれないことはないしてる
は金三茶の1個だから僕わかんないんですけどチョップが美味しいで続いてはもうこれ
を決めていたらいいでしょっチーズバーガー食べていきます簡単な話さっきのハンマー
にチーズを乗せただけみたいだこれであるんで大きな変化はないのではないかなと
を
寂しいないただきます
うんエナガお肉な子でも結局まいんざによって雪が by てきたとチーズケチャップ
味が成立してるんで全然多いする踏まえまずでうまくんだこれは普通にダブル
チーズバーガーいきますまあそん蛙とか一緒でしょ
タブンネチーズが一番多くなってるだけなんだなぁ
あってクルーズが年前になっている付ベビーいただきます
でしょベーコンレタスバーガーこれもベーコンが抜いてあるのでまぁれたスマートと
言っても過言ではないですね
僕のプライス
本当に入れたとしかねーなあの逆に系コース4でいいのではないでしょうか
いただきます
さあこれが良くない何か今までケチャップ買って食べてた気がするんですけどやばい
根ざすだけだとほんとにちょっと
[音楽]
次はチキンクリスプいきましょうチキンクリスプからねチキンを抜くと音もクリスプ
しかの方なんですね
はみ出すぎじゃないくれ主がどんなってなっていますね
レタスバーガーですよね沿っ確率もなくなるのかまずサラダのレタスバーガーじゃん
これ
ていた
やべぇケチャップの授業店気づいてしまいますね捨てちゃっぷないか本当にちょっと
と言ってでリア気迫バーガーせり上げ難題期待がかかっているかどうかがポイントです
ね
ないやーん
同じじゃんこれくらい
もう食えない長が焼き場行っキー食べていきます
あっでも性がかかっているこれちょっと期待ですないただけます
おうまるもまぁちょっと辛味がちゃんとある
年前中段へのば出ると結局はレタスバーガーなんだけどね信じるだがいきます
お肉食べたくなってきたいただきますん
ありがとうございます江口いきましょう江口打ちたいですよ
立ってエッグとチーズでしょお肉の用途がないんで
これはひょっとしたらいじってもないかもしれないですねまあやはり普通にえこれ普通
にハンバーガージャン卵も入ってるケチャップも入ってるピクルスも入ってるねこれ
こんなの本物かもしれないなっていただきます
うーんなんかよくわかんなくなってきちゃったよ big girl だけど全然
美味しいです
今のところ暫定チームもしれませんあればもうムードいっぱい降りる困るんかやまぁ
ちょっと頑張ろうグランティ f ランティア期からセリア気を抜くともグランしかも
今ないですねはい
と名トップメートルだけでもなく必ず良さそうですねっぬふわぁああああっ
[音楽]
をメモってくれるとこだった次リベリはいきます地聞いて a 4かなぁスキンを抜く
とどうなりますでしょうか
はいああああ
データでだいつものパターンこのドレッシング奴隷だといるときは2パターンですね
小泉
純粋に飽きたな全然にレタスを食い過ぎたところあるのグランベーコンチーズ
お前の血は何色だはいあーこれでも割と今そうだろ
いただきます
割といけるんじゃないかなや給食でグラスの女子の何人かがあんまり好きではないとか
イーツっても結構みんな食べちゃう系のパンなぜかしますねまあねグランクラブハウス
がフランスに山ば食べたことないからよくわかんねーんだよな
大
ためいたトマトがあるとね結構美味しくなる説あります
まあ美味しいアメリカ感が出てますね甘い甘いまあこれは何かで健康に良さそうな
ハンバーグ数
次行きましょうチキンタツタ行けます半できもーやばいつは2つじゃないとこういう
ことになるんですよね
だから俺から単にすごい量のパン食べてるみたいになってますいただきます
うわぁこれはパンがにすごいボリュームだからねもう
阿部でた繋がってるた種が予想ガイドにヤバイということはチキン食べたは家になると
いきましょうタッチたら姉と拮抗あってもとリトルポーズが入ってるって事を奪う祖父
タルタルソースは普通に食いたいいただきます
viper タルタルコンパイラやそんな状況下でも全然ねー
[音楽]
だるだる想像していない子はすごいお勧めだと思いますか
というわけでいよいよ残り3つに迫ってしまいましたエビフィレオフィッシュ
えっまあこれが銀行で優勝候補だと思うんですよ
bigman 区はお肉が抜きにしても特殊なソースが使ってあるのでソースでもう
美味しい気がしますねフェスタモード牛肉とか豚肉じゃないんでお魚がもう入って普通
のフィレオフィッシュになっていますエビフィルムもしかり
えびなんでこれを普通に指が入ってますでは
食べていはぞあとでガーター smac のおり9月さんをどうだってるって言われる
とこうなってるんですよねえロシターはあーでもこの頭数が実は美味しいんですよ
青ネギがなくても僕これだけで結構好きなんですよ
いただきます
それでもねや実際そうでもねえできるようないっしょ普通に服が入ってますよね
いただけます
甘いてビデオでおります
甘い竜星は heavy d 4 a
me
バッハ
お肉がない奴で一番おいしかったのは多分アグランカーブはずグランクラブハウスが
凄い美味しかったね
ニックの日だとブランクラバーしていく家が凄い美味しかっで普通の肉を食べない人も
いると思うんですけどこの2種類おすすめなんでぜひ食べてみてください
ぽって
フィフィで美味しいんだけど俺エビアレルギーなんだよ